in a New York Times piece of black lives
matters founder says says they never
meet with Donald Trump cuz he's Hitler
quote we wouldn't as a movement take a
seat at the table with Trump because we
wouldn't have done that with Hitler
Trump is literally literally the epitome
of evil all the evils of this country be
it racism capitalism yes capitalism
sexism homophobia blah blah blah it goes
on but does it matter what you're seeing
is a mass delusion where every action
proves a monster it's the same mania
behind the witch trials or when Ronald
Reagan was testing his microphone and
decided to make a joke
my fellow Americans I'm free to tell you
today that I've signed legislation that
will outlaw Russia forever in bombing in
five minutes now the media freaked out
over this like it was real which is what
happens with Donald Trump every single
day and that's key if you lose your mind
over every single word you will lose it
forever and then think he's as evil as
heavy metal was in the 1980s from some
of the fan magazines of a particularly
heavy metal that little sadomasochistic
outfits are advertised with the
fingerless gloves and spikes and studs
on them and that these the little S&M
outfits are marketed to to a teens and
preteens is that correct well they are
marketed who buys I'm not sure I can
sure pick a cause and he's the expert in
climate change but this is my point
Donald Trump is now death metal to the
left he's now a scare officially a scare
triggered by Trump's election the
aftershock creates uncertainty which
leads to this frenzy so to the left
Trump isn't just racist or insane but
now he's both and yet the Democrats lost
to him how nuts does that sound
but this belief that he is crazy the
evil that removes one-step dialogue that
used to prevent violence because to make
violence okay
you must demonize the target which was
done to cops
recently after years of demonizing they
became targets shots by fiends and DAP
Dallas in Brooklyn Louisiana San Antonio
who took pigs-in-a-blanket to heart you
think some people would learn but
delusions die hard when you only talk to
the deluded you know I have a feeling
Jesse when you call somebody Hitler and
say they're responsible for genocide you
really don't want to have a conversation
with them no here Trump is literally
killing people literally I just don't
like when people use the word literally
like that I also want to just run the
entire al gore every battle hearing can
we just run that forget health and
return at souk al gore and heavy metal
also notice what black lives matter also
said was evil capitalists yes and that
is the common denominator with all of
these outfits whether it's an Tifa black
lives matter Occupy Wall Street
capitalism is always evil now forgive me
if I'm wrong
Floyd Mayweather black guy yeah I just
made 300 million dollars on a
pay-per-view fight i watch that because
of capitalism okay is that wrong is that
is that wrong I would think black lives
matter would support that no though they
pick Colin Kaepernick another black
millionaire athlete because he's not
getting signed I mean talk about mixed
priorities then then you know it's
pretty the problem I also have with this
is black lives matter could have been a
decent movement you know if they just
focused on the justice and the equality
but when you compare the President to
Hitler and the chant about killing cops
it ruins all credibility Trump has done
more for black people and I think most
black lives matter people even realize
how many thousands of black people has
Trump hired over the course of his years
running the gaming industries running
The Apprentice in the real estate
industry promoted them given them
opportunities health care I don't think
Hitler would do that what do you think
why do you think Hitler would do that
Moke what a question Gregory Hitler
never opened a casino all right
and according to what people say about
how Trump treated his workers at the
casinos Hitler never told them to have
the black folks off the floor when the
big rollers were coming in but you know
what strikes me here otherwise no I said
that's what that's in books now but what
I'm saying is that I am struck by the
idea I think black lives matter is very
important move in this country and so
when you say the Akuma Hitler I think it
invites everybody's derision and decided
ignore it but when she went through the
list and said hey you know racism and
after charlottesville and the white
supremacists you know when she goes
through things like homophobia and you
think about what's going on with the
Trump ADAC taun transgender people he
was for gay marriage before Obama was
I'm just telling you he's chained he
sings a different song these days when
you think about his Jewish grandchildren
is he at the end he dotes on them I
guess he's I guess I guess you know
people like his Treasury secretary and
others who are Jewish in his own
administration who were speaking to him
now in harsh tones Rex Tillerson who
says to him you speak for yourself on
this I think there's something to think
this is not saying he is Hitler
I didn't say well you're kind of
validating everything she said no those
aren't actual real facts rose her
feelings where Darla feels madam no no
no you your interpretation of what he
did is a feeling it's not a fact it's a
feeling it's a feeling it is a feeling
about what he did to transgender millets
because because you were actually
ascribing your emotion into it
Kimberly thoughts all right so let's be
like rational here I'm obviously this is
ridiculous
they lose credibility when they make
these kinds of statements and when they
condone violence in general I agree with
you Jesse that they could be a very
powerful important movement if they you
know behaves in the right way and didn't
condone the violence that was happening
in Ferguson and other places and then
making bombastic statements like this
they have no and you no reason
whatsoever with truth and what's going
on and what the president is trying to
do it doesn't help them at all I mean it
just doesn't it alienates everybody from
them so there's nothing there's no
credibility to know Kimberly I just
think it's such a major moment in our
country with regard to racial tensions
how can you say that there's no there's
no validity to them no I didn't say that
whatsoever one but you love to try to
photos I have to give I want to get into
because I'm not having this go in the
press where you try to make it like I
said something like I do all the time
and I'm not having I'm not the bottom
line is I said they could they could
actually serve a great purpose to talk
about racial injustice yes like Martin
Luther King did and people that have
marched on both sides
white and black together to be powerful
to make sure there is equality for
minorities and for women but when you
condone violence I'm going to call the
presently United States yes they do then
they encouraged pigs in a blanket pigs
in a bubble one time Milwaukee March
well apparently Julian I got to get
chilly one thing she said which was she
said they would turn down the
hypothetical opportunity to interview
the president and I think that's a major
strategic blunder and I think it's that
kind of thinking that probably
contributes to the fact that they're not
as visible as they were a few years ago
if you're a civil rights advocacy
organization a political advocacy
organization you exist in order to
influence policy and the way you do that
is by talking to and negotiating with
politicians including those who you
don't agree with even if you think
they're Hitler or Stalin or whoever you
still have to have a dialogue and so
it's that kind of mindset I fear under
undermines the organization
you know they forgot to go we got to go
up one two yelling